happy to have laurent sakula and
lancaster borova
speaking on statistical physics and
computation in high dimension
the first lecture today will be given by
florent
please go ahead
all right uh i am assuming that you can
all see my slides
so i will start uh thank you nike
uh well it's uh it's a pleasure to
to to give the lecture of course i would
have uh rather
uh you know it would have been much
better to be uh
to be in simon's the united again but
next time i guess
and anyway thank you for uh the
opportunity to present
these sets of notes all right so this is
a series of four lectures
every day the next four days given by
myself and
lenka and
well uh this is some of
uh a brief outline so i will
today uh discuss statistical physics
method
all right the lecture is called
statistical physics and computation in
high dimension
and somehow you know this is not
orthogonal to the rest of the lectures
but it's rather different
and it involves effort from a different
community
so this first lecture will be well i
hope
clear and we'll try to to look a very
simple problem in order to expose the
ideas and the methods that have been
used by this uh community of people
you know in statistical physics and
mathematical statistics and then trying
to apply
to some problem in computations
right and tomorrow i will go into the
heart of the subject i will discuss
computational and statistical phase
transition
and once you will get the stage
then lanka will give you perhaps more
advanced
more recent results
uh and also open problems uh that we're
facing
uh also i want to add that i have a lot
of materials
connected to this course they can be
found here this address
it's a page that i set up for a lecture
given on these topics at duke university
two years ago
and thanks to our amazing tas we have a
very good lecture notes exercise
and even jupiter notebooks and also a
large part of the material can define
the review statistical physics of
interference
threshold and algorithm that was written
few years ago by
lanka and myself and it's an excellent
reference
for what i'm going to talk about
all right so let's start today
statistical physics method 101
all right it's not really 101 i'm gonna
i'm not going to teach statistical
physics
but you don't need to i think what you
need here is to have a dictionary about
the vocabulary used
in statistical physics with respect to
what you use genetically in computer
science and
more generically in probability theory
and this is what i'm going to discuss
today
okay and i hope the material will be
clear enough for everyone
okay first of all uh i just want to
mention that this ideas using
statistical physics for problems outside
physics
it's quite an old one i mean it started
from the 80s and we had
really great scientists who initiated
this
line of thought and in particular there
is this beautiful article written in 89
but nobel prize
winner p willie anderson when
he was saying that you know this new
tool that we are developing
around the statistical piece of spring
glasses might be very useful
outside spring glasses and it's a
cornucopia a lot of problems
can certainly be taken with these
techniques and certainly
he was right and that set of ideas
kept us busy in physics and in
mathematics
in the last three four decades
and i will try to discuss them today
okay so there are two types of problems
that i will be discussing
and for the two of them i will try uh to
use
statistical physics technique and try to
avoid as much as possible statistical
physic jargon
right but i also want to introduce you
to the jargon because this is after all
what you will find in articles so it
might be useful
anyway so sampling
okay so one of some of the problems you
can study with this technique are
sampling problems
and for instance base estimation
problems and that will be uh something
that
will appear a lot in this set of
lectures so here here is a type of
problem that we are discussing so let's
say you have a generative model
okay a probabilistic model so x is
sampled from distribution p of x that
you know
for instance it's a vector in d
dimension and then something complicated
happened
and from x you created y which is for
instance a vector in
n dimension and between the two
something complicated happened
but you have p of y given x you have the
conditional probability
right now y is your observation you know
the process you know p of y given x
and the question is how to find a good
estimator x hat for x
okay so this is a standard setting of a
bayesian estimation
and if you want to do base estimation
well of course you're using base theorem
when you write the posterior estimation
p of x given y
just be a way given x p of x over
normalization
all right so the trick is to rewrite
this
as taking the exponential of the log
here
and you know it doesn't make a big
change
but suddenly you can write things with
the statistical physics notation
which are extremely simple right now
here this quantity we have write it here
and we call it the boltzmann measure
and if we want to say that is 1 over z
exponential minus beta h well we need to
have a beta equal
1 and h is minus the log of this
quantity
okay this quantity is called the
hamiltonian in statistical physics for
historical reason
but less probability measure is the same
as this probability
now once you have a stability measure
you can define averages
physicists for some reason do not use
too much expectations notation
and they are really big fans of their
angle notation so these
will they not averages with respect to
that kind of motion
okay and this normalization here is
usually called the partition sum
all right so this is essentially the
wall story
and if you study the boltzmann measure
well you're a physicist
and of course there is a one-to-one
mapping between these two
and this means that any base estimation
problem can be mapped into some kind of
physics format
right the second type of problem that i
will discuss
and will be discussed in the set of
lectures are minimization problem
now it goes basically in the same way
let's say that you have a function that
you only nice over a set of variables
call it s you can call this a cost
function
this day in machine learning maybe
perhaps you will use the word loss
but you want to minimize and physicists
still will insist
to consider the word energy or
hamiltonian
in the same way you want to minimize
this okay
the way this is done well we can use
against the boltzmann measure we can
write simple probability distribution
both minus
exponential minus beta h or beta c
or beta l if you want to use the loss
you have the still
the same with smaller values the same
partition sum
but now you realize that as beta is
going to infinity
the probability measure will concentrate
on the minimum of the cost function
if it is well defined okay so
using beta which physicist called the
inverse temperature
this allows you to probe different
problems finite beta means sampling
and infinite beta means looking at
extremization
okay minimum and for instance it's
trivial to check like if you take the
log
of z and you derive it with respect to
beta
at any finite temperature it is giving
you the expectation of the inertia
and when you send beta to infinity then
you have the minimum
right and this is already telling us
that this object the log of
z with physicist called the free energy
will
be the fundamental one
all right so now we have set up the
notation and
what i want to do now is before going to
really interesting problem instead to be
looking at an extremely boring problem
it's a completely boring problem it's
really not interesting
but it has the following advantage if i
look at this problem
i can present essentially all the
techniques that i want
to tell you about and that will be used
in the next three
lectures in the set of
50 minutes or so so this is what i will
be doing
all right so look at the following
problem it's called the random financial
model
in in physics so we have n binary or
rademere variable if you want
so this binary variable can take the
value plus or minus one
and there are n of them now this is our
cost function
we call it hamiltonian because we are
physicists right now
and this is what it is it's just the
stair which is the sum of
s divided by n squared so minus sign
here
so if we want to minimize this well it's
easy what we need
is to have his asses to have all the
same sign okay all plus or minus
that will be the trick and we have this
additional term here minus
some of the i h
i what physicist called fields s i and
these fields these terms they are chosen
randomly
from a gaussian distribution once and
for all uh
with valence delta now of course western
would like
the variable to align with the direction
of the h
while this term we like the variable to
all have the same sign and there is a
competition between the two
all right and the term random field is
referring to this part it's actually an
extremely useful and important model in
statistical physics
all right so say now you want to
minimize this function
actually minimizing this function is
extremely easy
in fact here this is a problem defined
on a complete graph
because you have the sum of si squared
but in fact on any graph minimizing this
function is in p
there are many techniques that allows
probably to find the ground state so
it's not a hard problem
still it will serve as a very good
example for what i want to say
all right so the real question i want to
answer is this following one
now let's say that we're in i dimension
so n is going to infinity
okay this is the topic of simon's
meeting after all
and the question is what is the typical
value of the minimal cost when you
minimize this function
right or more precisely what is the
typical value of the mineral cost
divided by n
and we hope that this has a finite limit
they would like to know this number of
course we could run the algorithm for
many sizes and look at it but
the question is can we compute it
heuristically or preferably rigorously
all right so let's do uh what we came
here to do so we introduced the balsamic
measure
okay it's depending on n and beta
it's one over z and beta when this is
just the partition sum
okay so it's the sum of all possible
configuration of spins they are two to
the n of them
so there is no way we are going to do
this easily and then we know that the
minimum cost
uh is given by this expression when i
have added one over n
to lead to the correctly
all right now what we want here in the
question is the value of the typical
minimum cost
all right so i don't want to work with
something that depends explicitly on the
edges
so one thing you want to do is to
compute the average minimum cost
now i need to add the expectation here
which is expectation over
h's okay so whenever i use e
the variable i'm averaging about is a
disorder
if you're a physicist or the quench
disorder i need this field this set of
edges
okay so this is what we want to compute
all right now this means that this
object here
the log of z divided by n in expectation
is fundamental
and it's called average free energy and
this is what we are going to consider
for the next
uh for everything
that will be said today phi and of beta
alright so the first thing we might say
about this object
is just asymptotically the typical value
of the energy is very close to its
expectation
and this is why computing its average is
good we don't need to compute the
typical value we can just compute the
average because they are the same
and it's very easy to show that
typically
the log of z over n is equal to its
expectation
plus something which is of the order one
over square root of n in fact you can
prove this in few lines
there are many ways to do it but if you
just apply the gaussian poker inequality
you directly you get that the variance
of this random variable
is bounded by one over n and the
expectation of this derivative
and if you compute this derivative you
will see it's finite so the variance is
taking like one over n
okay now it's interesting uh that's the
reason why
physicists really wanted to compute this
average free energy
and they used to say this very nice word
the free energy is self averaging
right it's a quantity that when you send
n to infinity is equal to its average
and of course in math that's not what
you would say you would say that the
energy concentrates
okay but if you encounter the stem cell
for the edging
you mean is just a form of concentration
all right easy so what we have to do is
to compute the subject
how are we going to do this well it's
not so easy because
computing expectations is hard but
computing expectation of a log of a
function is usually very hard
because we don't have much control on
that we don't have
many integrals that involve the log
so in order to do so we are going to use
this uh one feet old tool from
statistical physics called the
replicameter
and first i will discuss it from the
physics point of view and you will see
that i will do a lot of things which are
really
mathematically let's say daring
or even wrong sometimes
but it will be okay and after this we
are going to see how we can do this
and obtain the same result rigorously
all right so this replica method is
actually an old beast
it appears in statistical physics thanks
to this man with some edwards
and actually some edwards himself said
that he learned it
in a conference by this man
with mark cats the same cats as cats
rice and many other formula and then it
was developed in statistical physics
into a very robust
and versatile tool especially thanks to
the breakthrough work of georgio parisi
and today thanks to the work of georgio
and marc mizar
we have the set of tools which is still
heuristic but
you know we can use it to attack many
many problems and compute
this average images okay how does it
work
so the idea is extremely simple
and you might even say trivial and in
fact the mathematical difficulty comes
here
directly so here is a trick when n is
very small
close to zero exponent the exploitation
of z to the n
is equal to expectation of n log z but
if n is small you can
tailor expand and it's one plus n log z
and so the expectation of z n is one
plus
n expectation of log c right so of
course if we send n to zero
the expectation of the log is given by
expectation of z to the n minus one
y this is easy and it's actually not
completely crazy to write this it's
perfectly fine
even for you may worry about permutation
of limits
but it doesn't sound completely insane
but this is not where the problem is so
here is it
so the way we do things is that we
evaluate the expectation of z to the n
for integrous values of n
because we know how to do it and then we
can interpret these copies
you know z to the two z to the three as
a replica of the same system this is
where the name come from
and then this is when the craziness
begin once we have the expression for
any
integral values of n we somehow assume
the expression can be analytically
continued
uh when n is in r which
actually is a very dangerous
mathematical things to do and
it's not well defined
finally once we have done this we send n
to zero the small one
then n to infinity large dimension and
we are also being very careless in the
order of limits and magically we robot
this works
all right so let's see how it works now
this is the part
which is the most boring part of the
talk because i'm going to show
computations now usually i do this with
a tablet or on blackboard but i don't
have a tablet now
so i am doing it on slides and i will
try to be slow enough so that everyone
can follow of course all the
computations are very simple
but it's usually hard to follow
computations on slides in fact i'm
always telling my student never to
present computations on slide
so i will do the exact opposite uh
of what i say and i'm sorry for this but
i think we can all concentrate for these
two next slide
all right let's try to compute z to the
power small n
all right this is the definition of what
it is exponential minus beta this is
hamiltonian
this is the sum of our configuration
it's to the power of small
n n is integer all right the first
change is that instead of taking this
power we say that
you know it's a product of n copies
each and this is indexed by
a letter alpha
all right and now what i'm going to show
you is the way you will write
this thing in any physics book okay
that's the way it's written in any
replica
computation that you will find in
physics literature and i think it's
interesting to
know how it's done in this community
okay the next step from here to here is
to introduce a delta function
i'm summing over all m alpha and i have
a delta that
makes sure that m alpha is equal to sum
over i of s
i alpha divided by n this means that
silently i can replace less there by
vesta
all right the way the computation
usually go and this is a standard field
curry trick
that physicists use is to say well i
don't like deltas
but the delta are fourier transform of
the following
expression so i'm using the fourier
representation of delta
right so delta is replaced by the
integral of m hat
which is a very poor notation because in
statistics of course hat is an estimator
it's not verse but this is what it's
used in physics
right we write the delta it's fourier
transform of this function
right now why did we do this
well we did this because now
the sun here can be pushed really here
and you see that we got rid of this
nastiest term here
that was somewhat complicated indeed now
we can purchase
some here all these terms here do not
depend on
s and now with hard computation summing
of the two to the n possible
configuration
is reduced to this simple term
and that is for each replica
but if you look at this you see that
these
actually can be factorized independently
over all side i
so you can actually perform this
computation the summation of the two to
the n
configurations and it's just giving you
a simple term product of
i of two hyperbolic cosine beta h i
minus i m hat alpha
right the whole reason physicists
introduce this change here
is to somehow arrive at the point where
the impossible to do
sum can be actually done in a very
simple way
all right now we did the half part it's
time to take averages so now we take the
expectation
with respect to this quantity respect to
h
now h the disorder is not appearing here
at all
and so you can push your expectation
inside here all right this expectation
of the product of
all replica of this quantity and once
you take the expectation
well this product here factorized also
so
it gives you a smaller end
so actually right now we have not done
so many um you know
everything here is still okay actually
we didn't do any uh crazy mathematics
for it
with a bit of effort all this could be
made rigorous actually
but let's go to the next part
all right so the next part is to realize
that we still
have to do this integral here and it's a
very complicated integral okay it's
n dimension and this is kind of funny
because
n eventually will go to zero so well
this is a weird thing
now this is where uh physicists look at
this object and say
look there is an exponential here of
terms with the power n here
so this will be exponentially large and
so
it looks like i'm going to be able to do
a saddle point here and if i do a saddle
point i will be dominated by some
special values
of his m-hat and m's
now one natural thing to do is to do
what is called the replica symmetric
assumption
let's assume that once i do this
integral it will be exponentially
dominated by values of m alpha
and hat that are all the same all the m
alpha equal to m
or m hat alpha equal to m hat
interestingly uh this is the part that
break
in more interesting computations and in
fact we know that the replica synthetic
assumption can be totally wrong
and the way to do a replica symmetry
broken or that
to find uh you know the correct
uh point that will you know will be the
correct saddle
is very tricky and it was something that
was understood by giorgio parrisi and he
basically guessed it
and it was a major achievement and it
took physicist
10 years to kind of believe that it was
a guess and mathematician in 10 15 more
years to actually be able to prove it
we are going you know i will try to
avoid replica symmetry like
all right so once you do this well this
expression is much simpler now
it's just an integral over the m d m hat
this sum here is just giving you a small
n here it's repetitive n i'm still
assuming that n is integral so it's fine
this expectation here well best thing
here is again
they're all the same so it's just a
matter of picking a power n here
and we are something much simpler
all right but another steps which is
very interesting and i know that people
are reading for the first time the
physics style computation are lost here
because they don't say it so i will say
it so it is clear for everyone
at this point what physicists do is to
use against replicating inside the
replica
right let's call this x we have
something here which is expo
expectation of x to the power n
now we are going to say fine and it's
going to be close to zero
so we can use the replica again
and somehow say well the expectation of
x n
will be close to exponential of n
expectation of log x
this is crazy right this is not
something we should expect to be true uh
in general uh of course if n is going to
zero
this is you know i mean it's a formal
computation
uh but it's clear here that there's
something weird
and in fact when you see this you start
to think if i'm going to prove this
at some point i will have to care about
the concentration of this variable
which actually turns out to be the
difficulty but never mind this
all right once we do this then this part
is written as exponential
and we are almost there because now we
see that we have an exponential with
n here all right now we somehow forget
that the small
n is small and we say large the large n
is going to infinity large dimension so
i can do a saddle point
if i can do a saddle point i will be
dominated by the extra normal moments
function
here it is
well if i am dominated by the extreme i
can compute for what it is for instance
i can make the derivation with m and i
will find that the extremization is
forcing
i m hat to be equal to minus beta m and
finally i find
the following expression which is the
final one so here it is
that's a full replica computation in a
sample case but
you know it doesn't get much more
complicated than this it gets more
tedious maybe but
the ideas are always the same right and
now physicists will say fine
now exponent the expectation of log z
over n
will converge to the extremum of this
function which is written
so we have replaced the evaluation of
the
intractable quantity uh with
something which is just you know one
dimensional integral and a minimization
process so it's a trigger
all right and once we are there
physicists are happy
they are looking for the extremum here
it's easy to extremize this function
in fact this is a fixed point condition
m star should be equal to
the expectation of the hyperbolic
tangent of beta h plus m star
this expectation is over the description
of h
and then you can put this in a computer
for instance here i use
h with a variance 0.1 and i'm plotting
here
many value of many plots of this
function see how it looks
it depends on beta so when beta is very
small you have something like this the
maximum
is at zero when beta is larger at some
point
you start to see that there are maximum
appearing here
and when beta is getting larger and
larger the maximum got closer to one and
in fact
this is what the maximum is doing and
star the maximizer is doing
this point where you have a drastic
non-analytic
behavior is called a phase transition
okay this is exactly what phase
transition here
now once you have done this you can send
beta to infinity and we can finally
answer the question
we wanted to ask at the very beginning
which is what is the minimal cost
this is the variance of the random field
and here it is
okay if the variance is zero it's minus
one half obviously
it's what you get when you have all
filled together and when you increase
the random field
you can get uh actually lower values and
until you reach this kind of object
all right that's the full computation uh
and that's the way it's
done in physics now there are many
reasons why you could doubt the validity
of
this computation for instance the fact
that you do this crazy analytic
computation
continuation and
one of the interesting questions we may
ask is can we do all that
rigorously can we do this from the
mathematician point of view and the
answer is
not entirely but for some problem we can
do it
and uh it has been largely due
at the beginning to the effort of this
two-period person this is francisco
guerra
and this is michelle in fact michelle
talagang
has written many interesting books and
made
fantastic progresses on uh obtaining
vigorous results for the replica method
interestingly
no one was able to prove that the method
is itself valid
okay that it's okay to continues
to go from an integer to end continuous
and everything
in fact i'm not aware of any result that
is able to say something on the method
what people did was to say fine let's
assume this is true
can we prove it and of course it's
always somewhat simpler to try to prove
something once your comment is true
so physics is giving you a good guess
here and uh
the question is can you prove it okay so
these are
very interesting references in the work
of michelle dargan
so all right now yes are there things
that the
method would predict that are not known
so is the method somehow more general
than the actual things which are known
to be proven
uh yes there are still many results
that we don't know how to prove and that
will be discussed
later on there are less and less of them
but we are not going to throw away the
method yet of course this is what we all
want right to throw away this and
replace it with
a principal uh technique
i think we are probably half way there
but we're not variants and
i will be discussing some open problems
later on well actually lenka will be
discussing open problems i will still be
discussing simple ones all right let's
see how we can prove us
and interestingly you know
you can do it rather shortly and the
techniques are
the same one that can be used for more
interesting and more complicated
problems
so the standard technique to prove is
formula is called guerra interpolation
due to francesco guerra in the early
2000s
and in fact the way to do to do it for
this problem
for exactly this problem here it's
something we walked out with jennings ii
and
de broga during our visit in berkeley in
the same months institute four years ago
this is where i was starting to be
interested by this problem and so
it's kind of nice to be back you know
even just really four years later and to
discuss about it
so here is how it works we consider this
new problem here which is not exactly
the random field problem because there
is a small
t here okay so it's a kind of fake time
and this is between zero and one
and you have m y minus t there
okay so now of course i'm discussing i'm
introducing the partition sum
and the boltzmann variable for this new
problem
now the interesting thing is that when t
is equal to one
this goes away and this is just the
problem we want to solve okay at t
one this is the randomizing model okay
so phi
n what we want to know is indeed the
expectation of log of z
and t equal one divided by n
and what we really want to know is the
limit when n is going to infinity
all right so the way you do graph
interpolation is by using well the
fundamental
theorem of calculus and you just say
well this quantity at t equal 1 is just
the quantity at t equals 0
plus the expectation of the integral
from 0 to 1
of the derivative with respect to t
okay and of course you have to be a bit
careful with the
expectations and integrals but it's
usually fine there's no problem here
all right now it turns out that these
terms are easy to compute the first one
here
at t equals zero well this thing
disappears so it's a set of independent
variables so you can compute it it's
trivial let's give this part
and this is nice because you can start
you know you recover
almost what we want if you have a good
memory realize that this is up to one
turn
the replicas may uh formula we are
looking for
the second part is a bit more tricky
okay you have this derivative of log if
you remember when you derive
when you make derivative respect of the
log well you start to see uh
boltzmann is occurring and so you start
to have this this thing here
and you have this nasty expression and
we have no idea to compute this right i
mean this is
essentially the expectation of the
average value of the variable
at finite t so for this world problem
and beta so we need to know it uh here
and then i need to integrate it so i
need to know it for all t there is no
way i'm going to compute this
i don't know okay but if you look
closely here you can
start to see that it looked like a
square this thing is squared and they
look like a
cross product so if we had plus m
squared in front well now it's good
because
if we had plus n squared and minus m
squared the minus m squared over 2
was exactly what was missing here to get
5s the replica symmetric potential
so this is exactly what is predicted by
replica and now the
plus m square over 2 is what you need to
complete the square
now we have the following for all value
of n at
every number of variables in all
dimension the free average energy is
equal to
the replica symmetric one with a value
of m
which can be a bit heavier at this point
by the way plus beta times the
expectation of this quantity
and of course the first thing you should
say is well this is a square it's
positive
so obviously this is going to be larger
than that and we have a lower bound to
phi n which is valid for all m
okay and that's typically what was
obtained by francesco
in the early 2000s even though we did it
for much
more complicated problems so did we
in germany but uh here you can see it in
a few lines and i think it's interesting
interesting example
so getting a lower bond is
is this just i mean did it just
coincidentally work out that you could
complete the square
is there some uh like deeper reason that
this
worked out to be fair i don't have a
good intuition
it always kind of work
except that you don't have always
squared for instance you might have a
power three
or four five in which case it's slightly
annoying and you have to think a bit
more and to try to use other trick
in fact when you do the famous tons of
factorization problem
you know in the order p you have a p
here
so you cannot use this technique uh
directly however it always look like
something like this and by the way
we know that m is supposed to be
it's supposed to be the magnetization
which is the typical value here so
investment concentrate
well it looks as this is going to go to
zero so it
you know it looks right but of course to
prove it is a
another story all right how do we get
the converse bound and this is the one
which is
usually harder and there are many tricks
to do it
i will use here uh one trick which i
learned from ahmed
uh llawi actually in berkeley as well
and it's an interesting trick
uh because it allows me to introduce
another quantity which is a constrain
free energy
all right now i'm going to use this
object the constraint partition sum
where i'm summing over all configuration
and i'm putting an indicator function
saying look i will keep
only the configurations when
the sum of variables are equal to n
times small
m right and of course then you you need
to put you must indicator function into
expectations and you can define
uh sorry uh now why is this interesting
well
if you sum over all m this quantity
of course you have the world partition
sum okay so
the constrained partition sum at finite
m gives you the relative weight of
configuration of magnetization
m in fact it's a way to set up a large
deviation principle
it's exactly what can happen all right
now it means that phi n which is
expected log of z
is really the expectation of log of z
sum over all possible value of m
of the constraint realization right so
this thing has a clear
meaning all right why is it interesting
well let's forget about this for a while
and let's consider
the constraint free energy okay so this
is the log
of z constrained at the magnetization
m right and now we are going to do the
interpolation for this object the
constraint free energy
okay it's totally easy to do it because
these are the exact same computation
that we did
except that you have an indicator
function so the constraint free energy
is
the one at t might equal one it's equal
to the one t equals zero plus integral
the derivative is just that now we have
these constraints here okay
now the first part this one well
the first thing you could remark is that
obviously
the constraint sum is smaller than the
total sum
so the expectation of the log of z
m is certainly smaller than the
expectation of log of z
so i can just say well look i will not
compute this i will just
bound it but what we had before
i could of course compute it but i don't
need to good
and then the second part well it's
exactly the same as before
except now well i have this measure here
which is constrained to value m
okay next step is just to complete the
square
and we have the same thing as before
except now but we have a low uh
we have a little equal here but now this
is where it's very interesting
because here we have this m minus sum of
the isi over
n but this average is considering only
values
when sum of s over n is exactly equal to
m
so this is going to zero
okay and we have this very nice result
but the replica
function is an upper bound to the
constrained free energy
actually we kind of believe that this is
true
maybe not at all n but asymptotically
this is what we actually believe
to be fully generic in the replica
theory even though i don't know how to
prove this
in full generality but here it's true
okay the constrained free energy gives
you a lower bound
uh okay the constraints energy is the
lower bound of the replica and the
replica is an upper bound
of the construction all right how are we
going to use this
to finish the trick well at this point
is
very easy and it's again something that
was
understood by a med you just say well
phi n is the log of z that is the log of
sum of m
of log of of the constraint the
partition sum
then you just say fine i'm going to
bound this by just keeping the max so
just there are two n values that m can
take
so i will just say it's smaller than 2n
times the maximum one
now there is a tricky part because the
maximum here can
change a bit when the disorder changed
so it can fluctuate from sample to
sample
so you have to prove that it does not
and it's very easy it does not because
the free energy concentrates
and once you can do once you do this
you can essentially write this and phi n
the true free energy is bounded by
the cost strange k energy evaluated at
its maximum
plus something which is order one i mean
it's you know log log
n over m goes to zero
all right so this is what it means in a
nutshell you have to do this a bit more
carefully that's what i did but
you know this is what it really means
all right and once we're here
well once we are here that is already a
nice result
uh and finally we are both bound
right that's what we had from the direct
government population
and using this trick phi n is smaller
than the constrained one which is
smaller than the replica symmetric one
and we have both pounds
and when n is going to increase to zero
that is sorry when
large n is going to infinity this is
going to zero we have a perfect sandwich
and we can take the limits and we
finally get uh
the rigorous result
okay and this is it and that's one way
to prove this formula i just want to
mention that
uh um there is a very interesting
much more challenging scheme uh that has
been developed by jean-bardeer nicola
matris
to to tackle similar problems in a more
complicated setting
it's called the adaptive interpolation
skin it's much more powerful that what
i've been showing
here but in this paper here this paper
on archive
they show exactly how their scheme work
for this simple random field rising
model and it's a
i think it's a very very interesting
exercise to understand how it works
before moving to
a slightly more complicated problem
all right now we have seen our replica
computation goes
we have seen some of the standard
technique that we have
to prove them but we have just seen
evaluation of free energies
all right and we want to speak about
computation and algorithm
so let's discuss algorithm
and in the physics community what we
really love is iterative algorithm when
you just
iterate the same equation many many
times
now that could be a wall uh class in
itself
uh and so i will just do a very brief
description
and again it turns out that for the
random field raising model you can do
things trivially
okay so let's do it
all right let's say that what we want to
do is to find the margin now
at finite beta we want to sample we want
to find
the expectation of isaiah for a given
problem
well the favorite algorithm from physics
is certainly called mean field
it was developed for this problem by
pierre curie and
pr vice at the beginning of the 20th
century and
then it made its way to machine learning
there is a
beautiful review by one brighter jordan
and if you write this
very nice algorithm here this is what
you get let's tell you that
maybe what you should do is to take
your estimate of the marginal
probability by the way you know
you just need the expectation to
completely characterize the distribution
of a binary variable so you just need to
know m i so m i at time t plus 1
is the hyperbolic tangent of beta times
h i
plus the average over all the marginals
it's an extremely simple
iterative equation in fact we are lucky
here because for any other problem
this thing becomes messy but
i see what it is now if you think about
what this algorithm is doing
and you want to say okay i want to know
what it is doing i want to track its
progress
and it's very easy you can write the
equivalent of state evolution
here so if you define m of t which is
the value of the expect of the average
value in your sample of
the marginals it's trivial to see
that m of t will follow the following
equation
right i mean this is m of t this is all
m
at the next step so asymptotically when
you have a large system you are just
taking the expectation of
h and this is what you have
right so it's interesting you can
entirely understand what the algorithm
is doing by looking at the scalar
equation
all right so why is this interesting
because this scalar equation here
is exactly the same that was giving you
that was giving you the maximum of the
replicafix point
okay and that's correspondence between
trying to
follow what iterative algorithm are
doing in this problem
in large dimension and
saying that they are trying just to find
the maximum somehow they are
really moving on this replica potential
and trying to find maximum
is something we find all the time and
that is actually at the root of our
interpretation of
computational hardness in this community
all right so let me uh you know briefly
uh
conclude what we have learned here what
do we have
well first we have this replica
potential we derive it heuristically
then we show to prove it
and the maximum or at least it's
extremum in general but
here it's the max gives the value of the
correct clean energy you can prove it
we have this interesting connection
between the constrained free energy
and the replica potential right we
actually saw that
the constraint free energy is the lower
bound to the replica potential for all
m with equality at the max
and finally it was very easy for this
problem to derive you know an iterative
algorithm
whose behavior is connected to the fixed
point of the replica potential
all right but that was a very simple
problem so why is less interesting so
the reason this is interesting
is that the exact same three points
can be made true for a very large class
of problem and that's basically
everything we are going to say in the
next three lectures
many minimization and something problem
on complete graph random graph
diluted graphs and so on and so forth a
large set of problems
when you study with that kind of
techniques you find these three points
sometimes you're not able to prove them
but at least heuristically this is
always what we find for a large set
of problems and so i think it you know i
thought it was interesting to to show
them how it works in uh this somehow
simple and one may save and trigger
okay and that's what we're going to
discuss in the next lectures and i will
assume that now you are expert
on this so you will know everything
all right so now for the last five
minutes i just want to uh
to give an exercise to those who want to
uh
check they have learned everything a
good exercise is to try to repeat the
exam
say computations that is the replica
derivation and interpolation type proof
for the spike matrix model so what is
the spike matrix model
so here it is uh let's say that you have
a generative model
so you have a generative model you have
a distribution
for a vector x star you sample x star
from it
let's say that x star is a vector in n
dimension so for instance it can be on
the three
it can be iid gaussian and it can be
each of these component can be random
error whatever
it can actually even be a complex not
factorized
distribution and now you are observing y
which is an m times n matrix a symmetric
one minute
which is defined as follow y i j
is one over square root of n x i star x
j star
plus the gaussian random variable
okay you are looking a noisy version of
this
product here which in fact is just a way
of saying that
y is a symmetric matrix which is the sum
of the random symmetric matrix
that we know very well plus the skunk
one
matrix which is what is called the spike
right and the kind of question you might
want to ask here is
if i'm giving you y are you able to find
back a good estimator of x star or not
so there have been tons and tons of
problems and discussions and articles
and works on this problem
i believe it was introduced by johnson
and donor
in the context of signal processing and
also statistics
all right now that problem
can be uh set up into a probabilistic
model well you just need to know find
what is the posterior probability of x
given y
well it's product up to normalization of
the likelihood time the prior the
likelihood
well this is just the gaussian so you
can drag on hamiltonian which will not
be too complicated you see you have this
quadratic term here
and when you somehow have to deal with
the prior if it is complicated it gets
more messy
then what we know from bayes optimal
estimation is that the best estimator at
least if you want to minimize the miscon
is given by the posterior mean
okay so you need to compute these areas
all right so if you repeat
the exact same step that i have shown
you for the randomizing model
for that problem it's slightly more
complicated but not too much
uh this is what you find first you can
repeat the replica computation physics
style
and it tells you that you've got a piece
of free energy here and the free energy
tells you but
you need to compute the maximum of a
replica potential and this is how it
looks
all right it's slightly more complicated
you have a two-dimensional integral
and a three-dimensional one if you
converse one
but all in all it's still a very simple
object and we also know
that the maximum of this function and
star
at least this is what we know from a
replica computation is telling you what
is the best overlap you can get
uh if you uh if you try to to solve the
base problem in fact the
optimal error is 1 minus m
you can repeat the guerra interpolation
in this problem
and this is what it gives the same kind
of result we already saw
in fact this is where we developed these
techniques
here so this result here was obtained
by jamming when we worked in berkeley
together four years ago and the
you know this overbound was much more
tricky uh i think we we first got it in
a very complicated way in this paper
with uh
bargaining atleast and and lenka
and tebow uh a much
nicer you know proof was then found by
uh
le large and neoland which was much
shorter uh then with ahmed we decided
that we wanted to be even more short and
we
used here the proof which is exactly
using what i told you a few slides ago
so it is
really using uh wisconsin free energy
and
then very recently there is again
another proof that was uh
shown by
clever uh anyway if you repeat what is
in this paper here you will get
this which i urge you to prove this
statement
and i didn't write it but it also allows
you to prove that m max
is the base optimal overlap
what about the third point oh yeah sorry
and for those of you interested the full
derivation is written
here and if you don't want to copy
this ugly
list of characters you can just go to
the set of notes that they left from our
duke lecture note and it's in chapter 6.
all right the third point was iterative
algorithm
and that's interesting because you need
to work a bit more
here to get an iterative algorithm it's
just not mean field in fact mean field
is not correct
means field will give you this part
but not that part this is called the
anzagarter but anyway you can work it
out
it's called approximate message passing
in fact it was called
the tap equation from tau lessons on
palmer in physics
even though physicists never thought of
it really as an algorithm
and then it was developed uh in the
context of comprehensing first by uh
i don't know montenegro 10 years ago and
there have been a lot of work in this
direction
and for the spike matrix model it was
written by sandy prangan and
ali fletcher all right this is how it
looks you have an iteration here
this vector are iterated with respect to
a which has
estimation of the marginal these are
estimation of variances
and anyway so i'm not going to enter
into the detail
because i will discuss this later on but
the point is
you can write a state evolution again
you can try to track
what the algorithm is doing for instance
if you want to know
how much your estimates of the x-star
correlate with its stars or
how much the overlap well you can define
m of t
to be overlapped between your estimate
at time t and x star
and you will find again that m of t
is following a sample recursion and if
you look closely at this recursion
well you realize this is exactly again
the same as the fixed point of the
replica potential
okay so this seems to be something that
we find all the time
but this algorithm that we like like inp
and
belief propagation they are just trying
to climb the replica potential
and this is again uh something that
we're going to use
later on
all right so that's all for today and uh
that was sort of a review of the
statistical physics methods
that will be part of you know of
this toolbox that was used to derive
many of the results that will be
discussed uh tomorrow in the next
three days let me again mention that
additional material
notes and exercise including the food
collection of the exercise they give you
which is quite the replica theory and
proof
for the rook one problem that we found
here
you just need to go to my webpage and
and there is a link so you don't have to
copy it and again uh i want to make a
shameless advertising of
uh our review with flanker
all right so i think my one hour is
basically up so it's probably a good
moment
to stop and i thank all of you for your
attention
thank you so much so there are a couple
of questions in the
chat um so there's a question from
renee carmona can you read it
all right let me go through the chat
okay uh chat
why am i here renee you can also
unmute yourself i think yes so i
i choose to mute so my
my question was mostly about historical
uh i thought that one of the early proof
of the
mathematically rigorous early proof of
the replica trick
was done using non-commutative
integration theory and requesting the
problem
as a fermion problem i have very vague
recollection from the mid
85 so
is that something different or is that
something similar
this one is this is like a bell crying
yeah yeah uh it rings a bell i'm not
familiar too much of this work so i'm
afraid i will not be able to uh
to really give a uh an answer here
uh but i can look it up and try to give
you a more informed uh
uh opinion i mean there have been a lot
of work
on these techniques so uh i i have
you know i am uh i have i am mentioning
very few of the things that have been
done uh for the proof of replica i don't
know about this one i mean i sort of you
know i ring the bell
uh there have been also amazing work by
michael eisenmann in princeton
also there are many many many techniques
that have been used these days what
people have been
you know been using to make the real
breakthrough is
certainly the interpolation and
certainly what was used by michelle
but i can look it up and give me the
reference
i have a question about the replica
method that you presented earlier so
for for many interesting models i guess
for any integer
n the expected value of z to the n will
be much
larger than the typical value of z to
the n
yes so then in such a model when you
apply the replica method
and you uh and you compute the value at
the replica symmetric
saddle point will that be correct for
integer n or no very good questions uh
i'm not even sure maybe i mean i uh
that's a good question i think
i would say that it should kind of work
i mean i remember that once you look at
the
continuous value of n you
you you start i mean a good exercise to
look at this
is the random energy model which is of
course totally serious
and i remember when when you go from n
large
and when it goes below z below one
actually things are okay and then you
have a phase transition at some point
uh so there is certainly you know i
would be willing to bet
that there is a finite value even the
continuous one in r
of n such that for all n
larger than this one uh things are
perfectly correct
and yes i think you are right i don't
see why
face value should be between zero and
one
[Music]
i think so too yeah i think so the
mercury
so the heuristic value of the integral
can be correct even if the
oh yes i think uh
you know what we do at finite n is not
totally crazy
except that we use these deltas and an
exponential of
you know in the fourier representation
but even this is not particularly
you know i i think with a bit of effort
this thing can be made uh
okay it's really when you start to take
this crazy analytic computation and
going to zero i mean of course
it doesn't make sense mathematically
right i mean the small n going to zero
while the big n is going to infinity
it's totally insane i mean even the
saddle point is weird right because i'm
you know when i want i'm saying oh small
n is small
and then large n is big then we should
start to worry uh with the velocity to
which you know the ratio is going to
and um i don't know i mean the more i
think about the method the less i
understand it in fact
myself i uh i like much more as you know
uh the cavity method which allows you to
to get the same kind of result
and it's still not rigorous but at least
they put this as on the table
right and so you know what you do um
i was very confused
i'm not sure i understand it it's still
a bit magic for me
so are there examples of things that you
can only get from replica and not from
cavity or vice versa
i don't think so i think they are
example of things
that you get with less computation with
cavity
and some that you get with less
computation with
uh replica right sometimes
you know for these fully connected
problems and complete graph
uh computation are usually shorter with
uh with replicas for instance if i try
to do the cavity
for um for the randomizing model i think
it will take me maybe a few lines more
as you well know if you try to work on
diluted random graph
you know erdogan graph coloring and all
this stuff
this is really hard to do with replica
in fact
you know all this work that we did on
sat and coloring and everything people
in physics did it
first with replica and they obtained the
same equation but
it was so long you know it was pages and
pages and pages
and after 10 page you arrive to what you
get from one
you know first place from the from the
cavity method
so you know it's it's really more um
what which one is a more uh you know
it's a better or
shorter heuristic to get the truth but
as far as i know any time we try hard
you know every time we try hard to use
the two methods
as far as i know they always coincide
so i don't know of anything when they
disagree or on problems where it's
not possible to use one and not the
other it's it's more like it's more
practical to use one
with respect to the other
oh sorry i have uh maybe a comment about
that uh
so florence can you get uh finite size
effects or fluctuations
uh using the replica method i know you
can get them with the cavity and that's
how
you can find any results yes you can
and it's it's uh and it's it's even more
crazy
uh so what you have to do is to make the
correction in
finite n small n all right and the
small n correction so the correction to
end to zero so i let you imagine what it
means replica space
because obviously it's going to be a
mess you can connect them to
fluctuations
uh financially effects and i mean
certainly fluctuations
of our stuff and again that was uh
something uh that giorgio was pushing uh
for a while uh and of course it leads to
it was of course very very hard for
mathematicians to say anything
i think really mathematics started to
progress
in this field when uh when the cavity
method was introduced because suddenly
things made sense and and
you know the iceland man seamster scheme
is all about gravity and
i mean some of the interpolation is a
totally different beast
you know we we could also entirely
forget about replica and try to do a
non-regular interpolation and probably
we can get all the replica results
uh the trouble with with the grower
interpolation
is that you know i did i cheated a bit
here i use a simple case but in reality
you have much as you well know actually
i mean you have a lot of terms
and then you have to work really really
hard to prove concentration
and this is tricky and if it is not in
some book by telegram then
usually we are lost
so there is one question maybe that's uh
you
didn't answer when you were doing the
computation so
when you write extremum or extremization
there is a freedom of choice in terms of
which saddle points you're gonna choose
and sometimes you have to choose the
right branch can you comment on that
yes uh so if you want to do it cleanly
it's very easy you know you can just
break the symmetry by adding a small
term
and that's what you know it's actually
an old trick in mathematics that's
the way people were defining deep states
uh
and so that's usually not a real problem
um but of course it's one of the problem
we are when we want to prove things
because for instance i said well
obviously
m is going to be equal to the expected
you know to its average
well that's not true uh
because what m will be you know the
description of
m strictly speaking is you know two peak
one at plus m and one and minus
m uh one of the nice things that you can
do with the constraints free energy
actually you did this
is to start to to prove constant
exponential concentration of a one peak
or two peaks
but usually this is you know something
that we have to care about
we have to break the symmetry and then
we have to care about
you know how the limit is taken and once
you do this a lot of things bad can
happen
and you know again you know everything
is okay for the
optimizing model everything is okay for
the rank 1 model
and once you go beyond this we start to
have difficulties
sort of like a more zoomed out question
which is
so you know you showed us the analysis
for this uh
you know curie west model uh but
but under what conditions should we
expect these
uh sort of methods to be successful like
oh yeah you can imagine if the
hamiltonian is really
non-smooth or something that things
would go really wrong so i i mean
can you maybe give like a sense of the
scope of this uh
approach yeah uh you know and i wish i
had a very
perfect good answer to this uh um
you know it's sometimes more of an art
than
one of science to to guess in advance uh
when it's gonna work
i mean you know physicists will tell you
well it always work when it means when
the midfield approximation is right but
it doesn't mean anything because you
know it's just saying that it works when
it works
and so far it works at least if you have
you know kind of homogeneous problem
and you also need to have the free
energy written in a way that it limits
it
exists which is actually a very
important problem
one of the reasons imp is breaking
for problem like tensorfactorization
is that transfer factorization invest
regime where you know sdp is working and
uh is a regime where actually the
physics computation is entirely crap
and if you want to correct this you have
to work hard for physics and again we
have to thank
ahmed and chris and alex from us and i
will probably comment on this but
one of the first thing is this one well
we need to be in a very nice regime we
need to have the high dimensional limit
such that things converge to a scalar
you know the free energy should be here
should be well behave should concentrate
and then i think that you know it's most
that we need to be able to do the
computation
and to be able to do the computation
well we cannot do
very complicated things you know this is
where things
should be homogeneous enough so that we
have nice integral that we can do
um now if you start to have things which
are very heterogeneous and you know some
kind of couplings
we have a weird distribution with fat
tails
well i will not trust directly committed
with my life in this situation
i will be willing to give it a try of
course but
so if you're on a grid for instance for
study if you if your interaction is on a
two-dimensional grid
there is no way the replica method is
gonna work well
it's it's not really that it's not
working actually it's just that we have
no clue how to compute anything right i
mean we don't know to compute the
we don't know to compete with moments on
the grid uh
maybe if we would be clever enough to
compute you know
all the you know integral moment of zn
and and find the correct
all that of minimizer or during the
saddle point maybe it might work
we just have no idea to do it you just
have absolutely no clue to do it
in 1d we can do it
in some 2d problems somehow we can do it
by you know
cheating a bit uh for instance this is
what some of my friends doing uh you
know quantum computation we talk about
fermions
now fermions it's sometimes the way to
add the dimension but yeah we have no
idea how to do this thing uh
on grid absolutely no ideas but it's
you know i don't know if it is because
the replica method is wrong
mostly we have no idea to do the
computation i see
so you know i think the answer to your
question is
if i'm able to do these computations
i'm willing to to to to call the results
uh
a clever conjecture
mostly the problem where you cannot
apply it as a problem where you have no
idea how to apply it because this is too
hard
sure okay thanks
okay we have one more quick question
from the chat uh someone asked can you
comment on how to design the
interpolation path
oh very good questions well again uh you
know if
there is you know what we really would
like to have
uh you know i think the point will be
solved from from a mathematic point of
view
when we will have the answer to this
when someone would write a book
saying okay for this problem this is
interpolation scheme
then you have to work out to work and
you get the answer
then i think we can just forget about
the replica method we'll have a
perfectly principled mathematical
setting right now you need to be
imaginative
uh in fact the book by michel calagra is
showing a lot of imagination into ways
to do this smart path approach
and recently there was this very nice
paper by jean-barbier and nicola marquis
that was then
you know further used by lomiolan when
we used it to prove some results
and here what they use is to say you
know why do you use the scalar
m in the interpolation you can use a
function m of t
and then you start to have a lot of
freedom and it's extremely powerful
and you know you can start to prove very
complicated results with this
but to be fair it also becomes
mathematically much more difficult
to have everything under control because
incidentally you start to say okay now i
have a function m of t my interpolation
path
this function will be the solution of a
differential equation
but then you have to worry if you have a
differential equation as a solution
you have to prove it's unique and then
you realize that you oh yes but ahmed
told me that i need to break the
symmetry so you need to break the
symmetry
oh but maybe by breaking the symmetry
i'm killing the solution so you have to
worry this is not happening
then it's okay then you know and then
you you need to
send this thing that breaks the symmetry
to zero and that also can hurt your
solution
so this tool uh the adaptive
interpolation is an extremely powerful
tool
but it's also very delicate to use um
and uh but i think it shows that there
are a lot of uh
unexplored uh directions into the
interpolation scheme
and uh well i would say that uh you know
use your imagination
i mean of course one way to help you
design the interpolation scheme is to
know in advance the replica result
and the thing that look ugly in replica
you say this is what your interpolation
should give you at time zero and
the part that looks okay you hope it
will pop up when you integrate from zero
to one
but it's more of a guess work than
of uh
an exact tool right now
okay i think we have time for one more
quick question and i think
any of you to ask the question uh how do
i ask
hello yes i hear you
uh so my question was uh i i saw that
you have written the papers trying to do
the replica trick on neural nets also
uh yes well you know it's it's it's not
me
uh you know but that's one of the first
application of the replica method and
people were crazy
about this in the 80s i've been tons of
work on
very simple nets and of course now we
would like to use this for more
complicatedness
recently i saw two papers where you have
tried to use replica
method for neural nets but i felt that
it is somehow not working for the red
you get am i right in the understanding
that the replica triggers again
you you you went off at some point uh i
i think from the paper what i got was
the replica trick is not
working with the value gates is that
correct
well i don't know i don't see why i mean
maybe
computations get more complicated with
rules and so
you know you might not be able to get uh
answer but i don't remember at least i
never wrote this
no i i that's what i felt from the paper
that some of the assumptions excluded
the value video i wonder i was wondering
if you have any comments about
why they're maybe i don't know i mean
you know but it's it's like the answer
to it's a little
questions you know sometimes it's just
that you have these computations you do
them and you realize that things are
much nicer
if your activation is even or odd or
something
and you restrict to this because it
gives you nicer formula
so i think if if we did it this way it
was just because we wanted to have nicer
and simpler formula
but i don't see why the rollergate
should be any problem so i wanted to
get your comment on what is the long
term view there like if you could get
the replica trick to work on neural nets
what is the end goal there would be like
what would you be able to
hope to be able to say about neural nets
from replicas all right that's a great
question
uh and uh but i think they should be
reserved for lancaster boroba because
she's
probably going to talk about vince like
this so
i i will let her answer and
lecture three or lecture four
but the answer is that we have a vision
of what we would like to do with it
okay you have a one line statement what
the in the goal of the replica check on
your letters
oh well you know there are many things
you might want to do i mean
one of the thing is of course to try to
understand the landscapes of this object
that's
the line of thought around you know
general benefits vision
what we would like to do is to say well
can we compute the generalization
properties for a large set of
problems without actually running
an algorithm can we help design
nets can we understand when it is easy
and how to train the net for such and
such that
that kind of thing this is really our
long-term goal here
is there a concrete formula known like
replica trick working on neural nets
implies something about the
generalization error or the
landscape there are things that there
are things that we know but only for
two-layer networks now
so i don't know what you call this a
real um which people can see this
formula
um i you know
i think lenka is going to talk about
part of this so you know
give it one day or two and uh okay
thanks a lot for the
discussion no problem
okay thank you so much laurent uh so i
think we'll
end here so that the next speaker can
get set up and
uh we have a reception on gather time
for the next about 10 minutes
so we'll see you all soon